En VisualPolitik, en cuanto tenemos oportunidad,
nos gusta hablar de Asia y de su cada vez mayor protagonismo,
lo sabéis ¿verdad?
En varios vídeos os hemos hablado ya del
impresionante desarrollo que está teniendo
este continente y también de las increíbles
oportunidades que puede albergar.
Sin embargo, no todo es de color de rosas…en
el nuevo corazón del mundo, en Asia, también
podemos encontrar… cómo decirlo, algunos
claroscuros…
Bueno, decir esto es quedarse tal vez muy
cortos, porque amigos, Asia, la tierra de
las oportunidades, como nos gusta decir aquí,
en este canal, tiene también caras menos agradables.
Y sin duda, la peor de todas es que esta tierra
se está convirtiendo en un gigantesco polvorín.
Tal cual.
Por un lado, esta zona del mundo cada vez
gasta más en armas, de hecho, se espera que
para 2020 la región suponga ya más del 30%
de todo el gasto militar en el mundo.
Y encima se está convirtiendo, creedme, en el gran tablero de ajedrez de la geopolítica.
Fijaos, China y la India son grandes potencias
emergentes que cada vez más reclaman una
porción de influencia mayor, la Rusia de
Putin ha empezado a poner su atención en
el pacífico, Estados Unidos también…
Vamos, que hoy por hoy esta zona del mundo
está más cotizada que las entradas al palco
del Bernabéu.
Por otro lado, las discrepancias entre países
están a la orden del día.
En Asia, últimamente parece que cualquier
excusa es buena para querer darse de bofetadas.
Así que, podemos encontrar conflictos de todos
los colores y por todas las causas: económicas,
territoriales, históricas…
Qué si, conflicto de China con Vietnam; de
China con Japón; de China con la India; el
caso de Taiwan; las disputas entre Japón y Rusia;
la situación en Korea … Y, bueno, así una larga
lista de desencuentros.
Hablaremos mucho de ellos, pero hoy nos vamos
a centrar en el que podemos considerar un
gigante dormido… Y por cierto, uno de mis
países favoritos: Japón.
Japón es la tercera mayor economía del mundo.
A pesar de lo cual, este país ha tenido en las
últimas décadas un papel más que discreto
en la política internacional.
Sin embargo, esto está empezando a cambiar
sobre todo por dos motivos: China y Corea
del Norte.
Primero, clarísimamente, la emergencia de
China como nueva superpotencia y ¿Por qué
esto le importa a Japón?
(Pues porque políticamente no son dos países
que se lleven precisamente bien, y desde luego
la emergencia de China supone de facto un
retroceso en la influencia regional de Japón,
Por si fuese poco ambos países mantienen
un agrio conflicto por la soberanía de un
pequeño archipiélago conocido como las Islas
Senkaku.
( “Las Islas Senkaku, están abandonadas,
pero siguen siendo un punto clave para la
industria pesquera, poseen yacimientos de
petróleo y gas, y también son un enclave
estratégico para el comercio marítimo.”
Pues bien, fijaos en el siguiente gráfico
para ver cómo ha evolucionado el presupuesto
militar de ambos países en los últimos años
y entenderéis la preocupación que Japón
tiene por la emergencia de China
Luego, y de más actualidad, está Corea de
Norte.
(Desde hace 20 años el régimen de Pyongyang
está enfrascado en una carrera por desarrollar
capacidades de guerra no convencional, esto
es, fundamentalmente, sus capacidades de guerra
nuclear.)
Hasta el momento ha conseguido fabricar una
bomba atómica de 30 kilotones, que viene
a ser algo así como dos veces la bomba de
Hiroshima. Y también ha logrado fabricar
misiles balísticos que podrían alcanzar
no solo Corea del Sur, sino también Japón.
(En marzo de 2017 Corea del Norte lanzó cuatro
misiles balísticos contra Japón.
El ensayo tuvo relativo éxito y 3 de los
4 misiles cayeron en aguas territoriales de
Japón, a menos de 200 millas de la costa.)
Pues bien, todo esto está generando auténtica
psicosis en el país nipón:
El propio gobierno japonés ha comenzado a
practicar evacuaciones ante un hipotético
ataque y también ha distribuido una guía
que detalla cómo los ciudadanos japoneses
deben responder si Corea del Norte lanza un
ataque nuclear sobre el país.
(Según el gobierno los ciudadanos tendrían
unos 10 minutos para reaccionar desde que
fuesen avisados por un sistema de alertas
nacional preparado para notificar a la población
un ataque inminente por mensajes de texto,
radio y televisión.)
Sin embargo, el tiempo disponible podría
ser incluso menor.
El caso es que además de disparar la preocupación
de todos los japoneses, la amenaza norcoreana
está disparando el negocio de refugios antinucleares
y, también, la compra de dispositivos de
purificación del aire diseñados para combatir
la radiación o el gas venenoso.
Bien, sea más o menos cierta la amenaza norcoreana,
el caso es que estas dos cuestiones: China
y Corea del Norte, son las grandes amenazas
percibidas por Tokyo.
Pero antes de ver cómo el país planea hacer
frente a estas amenazas, veamos cuales han
sido en las últimas décadas las bases de
su política de defensa.
Como todos sabéis, Japón fue uno de los países
que perdieron la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Como consecuencia de esta derrota, en 1947
se le impuso al país una Constitución, aún
hoy vigente, que explícitamente renuncia a
la guerra y al uso de la fuerza excepto en
caso de defensa propia.
Es decir, en un principio se contempló que
Japón no pudiera tener ejército.
La protección del país correría a cargo
de Estados Unidos.
(Sin embargo, la guerra de Corea y la escalada
de tensión en la Guerra Fría, lo cambió
todo: de repente tanto Tokio como Washington
entendieron que era indispensable que se crease
una fuerza de apoyo a las tropas estadounidenses
en caso de que hubiese que defender Japón.)
Así, nacieron Fuerzas de Autodefensa de Japón,
una especie de ejército cuyo único cometido
posible es la defensa.
Eso sí, formalmente Estados Unidos continúa
haciéndose cargo de la protección de Japón.
De hecho, la potencia americana tiene desplegados
en este país más de 40.000 soldados y algunas
de sus mayores bases militares.
Una fuerza, que, por cierto, es financiada
por el propio gobierno de Japón.
Y ojo, el gobierno japonés no solo financia
estas fuerzas:
Podemos decir, que Japón es la gran punta
de lanza de Estados Unidos en Asia.
Sin embargo, el nuevo escenario que hemos
visto respecto a China y Corea del Norte ha
hecho que Tokio ya no se conforme con esta
protección.
Veamos, ahora si, cómo está respondiendo Japón a estas amenazas.
En primer lugar, el Primer Ministro de Japón,
Shinzo Abe, ha iniciado una inusual carrera
diplomática para intentar contrarrestar el
creciente peso de China.
De momento ha conseguido mejorar las relaciones
con Corea del Sur, fortalecer los vínculos
con Estados Unidos e incluso tender puentes
con el Moscú de Vladimir Putin.
(Japón también mantiene una intensa disputa
con Rusia por la soberanía de un pequeño
archipiélago conocido como las Islas Kuriles
que a día de hoy están bajo soberanía rusa.)
De hecho, la diplomacia puesta en marcha por
Abe es tan intensa que incluso la competición
con China ha llegado a África:
Y bueno, Shinzo Abe también fue el primer
líder internacional en reunirse con Trump
en la famosa residencia que el Presidente
de Estados Unidos tiene en Florida.
En este encuentro parece que Abe consiguió cuajar
un buen entendimiento con Trump.. y eso que
durante la campaña electoral Donald se quejó
bastante de Japón, pero… bueno, las cosas
pueden cambiar.
Pero claro, la diplomacia no siempre es suficiente…
Y llegamos al punto clave.
(A menudo se interpreta que las Fuerzas de
Autodefensa de Japón son una especie de banda…
para nada.
Su armada, por ejemplo, es más grande que
la de Francia y Reino Unido… juntas.)
Es verdad, su nombre puede hacer que no le
demos importancia, pero las capacidades de
este peculiar ejército son espectaculares.
Para muchos analistas continúan siendo el
mejor ejército de Asia, a la espera eso sí
de que China finalmente le arrebate ese puesto.
Y es que ojo, aunque Japón invierte relativamente
poco en defensa, menos del 1% de su PIB, esto
supone mucho dinero...
(En 2016 Japón fue el séptimo país con
mayor gasto en defensa.
En 2017 destinará a sus fuerzas armadas el
mayor presupuesto de su historia, más de
5 trillones de yenes, unos 45.000 millones
de dólares.)
Mucho dinero en un ejército muy pequeñito
y, por cierto, muy bien entrenado, da para
hacerse con los sistemas más modernos:
por ejemplo, el F35, los mejores drones de
EEUU, los portaaeronaves clase izumo – bueno
para los japoneses destructores defensivos
o el nuevo caza de quinta generación de fabricación
local que está desarrollando Mitsubishi
El caso es que desde que Abe se convirtió
en Primer Ministro de Japón en 2012 ha tenido
claro que había que dejar atrás la vocación
pacifista fijada en la constitución japonesa.
Y dicho y hecho:
En 2014 levantó las restricciones a la exportación
de material bélico con el objetivo de impulsar
una auténtica industria militar japonesa;
en 2015 Abe lideró una reforma para que las
fuerzas de autodefensa pudieran operar en
el exterior. Hoy tienen, incluso una base militar en Yibuti.
Y por supuesto el presupuesto militar ha vuelto
a incrementarse tras muchos años de recortes.
Y ahí no queda todo, ahora incluso se habla de cambiar la Constitución…
Bueno, tú que opinas ¿Debe Japón dejar
a un lado su compromiso pacifista?
¿Debe hacer guiños y cesiones a Pekín?
¿Qué país te parece un mejor aliado, Japón
o China?
No dudes en dejarnos tus respuestas en los
comentarios y darle a like si te ha gustado
el vídeo.
Por cierto, tenemos un mensaje que trasladaros
desde VisualPolitik: Queremos daros las gracias
a todos los que desinteresadamente habéis
contribuido al canal con una aportación en
Paypal.
Nunca lo hemos pedido, pero a pesar de ello
muchos habéis decidido echarnos una mano.
Haya sido mayor o menor vuestra aportación
¡Muchísimas gracias!
No solo nos ayudáis a sacar adelante este
canal, también nos facilitáis que podamos
pensar en poner en marcha nuevos proyectos.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.